mais d'abord donc l'enseignement
principal de notre baromètre de décembre
la percée fulgurante de valérie pécresse
qui devient une rivale sérieuse pour
emmanuel macron nicolas fleury
elle pourrait être une rivale de taille
pour emmanuel macron dans un nouveau
sondage valérie pécresse gagne 12 points
de popularité en un mois dynamique
compétente auprès des sondés la
candidate lr améliore son image même
s'ils sont peu nombreux seulement 38% à
lui prêter la stature d'une présidente
de la république ce matin ses soutiens
la voit déjà au second tour on dit
toujours tes d'abord rassemblés dans son
parti mais là on voit bien qu'elle
commence à élargir parce qu'elle a un
vrai projet elle a une vraie dynamique
qu'elle a une énergie très importante
donc bien entendu ça déstabilise
complètement en fait l'elysée en
laissant très très fébrile emmanuel
macron inquiet estime les républicains
car le président a choisi de s'exprimer
demain soir sur tf1 au moment même où
valérie pécresse devait participer à une
émission politique sur bfm tv la
candidate a dû repousser l'invitation ce
qui irrite sa famille politique ça
commence à devenir limite limite pas
pour la démocratie ça fait beaucoup
parce que comme pour le moment il n'est
pas officiellement candidat son temps
n'est pas décompté comme candidat alors
que le temps des autres laits valérie
pécresse veut saisir le csa et d'autres
adversaires des manuels macron s'indigne
de ce grand entretien on peut imaginer
que les autres candidats n'auront pas
des conditions aussi favorables
permettant de choisir les journalistes
probablement les thèmes
film et ce à quatre jours avant d'après
notre sondage publié aujourd'hui avec
aux doxa emmanuel macron reste pour
l'instant le favori de la prochaine
présidentielle
et en analysant tire les leçons de ce
baromètre avec évidemment gaël sliman le
président de doxa bonsoir
venu gaël nathalie mort et bonsoir
janséniste politique au groupe ebra
l'est républicain les dernières
nouvelles d'alsace ou encore le progrès
mathieu sous pierre bonsoir expert
associé à la fondation jean jaurès et je
rappelle que vous publiez 2022 la
flambée populiste c'est aux éditions
plon laetitia cru pas et atterrissent
politique bonsoir laetitia bienvenue à à
vous aussi allez l on commence avec vous
comme comme de tradition quand on
dévoile en détails les résultats du
baromètre quelles leçons vous tirer
leçon global on va on va vraiment parler
de valérie pécresse puis du duel avec
emmanuel macron enfin de la gauche
la leçon au sommaire le pitch comme on
dit c'est un président de la république
je disais déjà le mois dernier qui a des
niveaux
exceptionnels de popularité pour un
président en france au tout de suite
relativisé parce qu'il ya une majorité
de français qui disent c'est un mauvais
président mais pour la france dépassé
les 40 % de popularité c'est magnifique
il est à 44 % on est à quatre mois d'une
éventuelle réélection enfin tous ses
prédécesseurs n'auraient même pas osé en
rêver donc ça c'est très bien pour lui
on détaillera mais il arrive en plus à
se maintenir à des niveaux qui sont tout
à fait satisfaisant auprès des
sympathies aux prêts dès l'arrêt mais
évidemment des sympathisants de son
parti mais auprès des sympathisants de
gauche s'en sort pas mal et auprès des
sympathisants aient l'air aussi donc on
pourrait dire tout va bien pour emmanuel
macron s'éteint c'est une autoroute un
boulevard sont source à gênés
et ben voilà sauf que jusqu'à présent
tout allait bien parce que tout était en
ligne on avait une marine le pen ou
encore mieux éventuellement un eric
zemmour comme potentiel adversaire au
second tour ça veut dire match plié
d'avancé victoire écrasante - écrasante
qu'avant mais a priori quand même
écrasante sauf catastrophe et puis là
tout change
investiture de valérie pécresse on
pouvait s'y attendre on en avait parlé
sur ce plateau les mois précédant à
chaque fois qu'il y ait une primaire
celui qui gagne une vraie primaire je
suis qui gagne la vraie primaire qui
mobilise des dizaines de milliers de
personnes un bonze dans les sondages
d'intentions de vote à la présidentielle
c'est arrivé à fillon c'est arrivé à
benoît hamon avant qu'il ne redescende
c'est arriver à tout le monde en fait et
donc ça arrive à valérie pécresse et ça
se traduit dans les intentions de vote
et ça se traduit dans notre baromètre
politique où elle grec sur deux
indicateur distincts un indicateur tout
simple de popularité bonnes opinions
mauvaises opinions 12 points c'est
spectaculaire et sur notre indicateur un
peu plus comment dirais-je complexe sur
la côte d'adhésion kir qui ressemble un
peu plus potentiel électoral on va dire
elle gagne aussi 12 points et elle
devient elle est immédiatement propulsé
à la deuxième place des personnalités
politiques préférées des français
derrière saint-édouard philippe qui est
indétrônable
donc il se passe quelque chose
effectivement ça de quoi inquiéter
emmanuel macron et son entourage
nathalie morin vous avez couvert la
primaire lr est ce que vous êtes
surprise malgré tout par cette percée
non par l'ampleur de cette personne et
non pour une raison simple c'est que les
sympathisants et l'air ont une envie de
gagner que vous n'imaginez pas et là
elle a été très intelligente c'est à
dire qu'elle a réuni son camp pendant
une semaine elle ne s'est occupé que de
ça l est pas parti skier à courchevel
comme l'avait fait françois fillon il ya
cinq ans et elle a mis du lion partout
donc elle a dit oui à beaucoup de gens
les ailes on l a intégré les équipes et
c'est ça c'est au niveau j'allais dire
des chapeaux à plumes mais au niveau des
sympathisants moi j'en ai rencontré
beaucoup et j'ai rencontré les cadres la
mutualité l'autre jour j'ai rarement vu
un parti non pas unie parce qu'il faut
pas rêver mais concentrée sur un même
objectif ça fait depuis dix ans qu'ils
ont perdu le pouvoir ils ont une avis
une envie incroyable de le retrouver
c'est valérie pécresse ok on y va ça
aurait été un autre qui serait mis aussi
j'en veux pour preuve elle avait quitté
les élèves et il est à l'air ne lui en
veulent pas du tout dans votre baromètre
qu'on a publié ce matin aussi les
sympathisants à l'air sont derrière elle
comme si de rien n'était comme si elle
n'avait pas quitté la maison donc oui
ils sont pour reprendre votre question
tout va je suis pas étonné l'iran ndlr
ont envie gagner c'est ça ma mathieu
soutien ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ça lui a vraiment servi de rampe de
lancement puisque on peut comparer à
d'autres primaire même récente j'allais
faire il ya effectivement l'effet
booster qu'on a connus par exemple en
2017 mais avec des niveaux de
mobilisation considérable là il ya eu
une autre primaires c'est celle de
yannick jadot qui avec des parallèles à
tout à fait une primaire parce qu'on est
sûr
vingt mille trente mille elektra ces
tout-petits quoi personne n'a rowling
alors pour ce qui est des sympathisants
mais en l'occurrence on avait le même
nombre de candidats ou à peu près le
même nombre de votants ou à peu près le
même immédiatement des voix ou à peu
près au premier tour et un écart un peu
plus significatif en faveur de valérie
pécresse mais pas tellement et un pôle
de radicalité incarnée par son reer ou
sur d'un côté mais eric ciotti de
l'autre qui par ailleurs au départ
commencé par contester un peu la
victoire du gagnant en disant c'est vrai
vous avez gagné mais j'ai fait un
tellement bon score que j'ai un peut
gagner aussi mais pourquoi pas ce cap à
l'unité affichée à laquelle on assiste
là depuis dix jours chez elle est en
tout état de cause les mêmes causes ne
produisent pas les mêmes effets yannick
jadot a pris 0 points à l'issue de sa
victoire et c'est même relativement
inédit alors même qu'il incarne
l'écologie thème aujourd'hui hautement
consensuel il ne prend aucun point sadi
sans doute que valérie pécresse
effectivement est tout de même soutenu
par un peuple de droite qui est
infiniment plus disciplinés que nollet
par exemple l'électorat volatile écolo
sans doute mais encore une fois je
j'entends que les spécialistes de dlr ne
sont pas surpris je ne suis pas sûr que
beaucoup auraient néanmoins miser
beaucoup de jetons sur un bond de 12
points alors là on parle de popularité
mais on voit bien que toutes les
enquêtes depuis une dizaine de secondes
en six points enregistrés en intentions
de vote exactement la même chose je
crois que l'institut qui donne la plus
la plus forte hausse ces +11 points en
trois points en trois jours alors ça dit
sans doute qu'il y a un petit effet
valérie pécresse qu'elle a fait là q que
l a gagné alors qu'on ne l'attendait pas
qu'elle incarne une forme de modernité
peut-être pas dans son programme
peut-être pas dans son style mais au
moins dans le fait qu'elle est une femme
etc etc encore une fois on ne
l'attendait pas on verra ce que ça donne
je pense que quelqu'un qui prend 11
points en trois jours peut tout à fait
perdre 11 points en trois jours aussi
voilà ça dit surtout je pense que
l'électorat et d'une volatilité inédite
on l'a vu avec eric zemmour qui flambe
en quelques semaines on l'a vu avec
marine le pen qui dévisse aussi en
quelques semaines il paie d'ailleurs si
on regarde
les enquêtes d'opinion il ya encore
énormément de français qui disent je ne
sais pas bien sûr je ne sais pas pour
qui je vais passer dans
on le fait à chaque fois quand on
présente les résultats du baromètre on
est évidemment humble face à l'évolution
possible c'est je te fasse et pas les
résultats fait que 2 du 10 avril on
tourne est en train de parler non ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on ne
sait rien
pratique
que ce rebond est finalement était
attendue est assez classique ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'un parti politique
finalement les partis ne sont pas morts
voilà emmanuel macron avait clamé sa en
tout cas les maquereaux ni stelmak
revenir je vois comme andy avait clamé
sa au lendemain de la victoire
d'emmanuel macron visiblement non
puisque quand on est porté par un parti
comme valérie pécresse la progression
est beaucoup plus stable yannick jadot
ça montre aussi que peut-être l'écologie
n'est pas encore organisé de façon
structurelle en france comme le sont les
partis traditionnels pardon pardon
laetitia l'écologie a fait un bien
meilleur score meilleur score que la
droite traditionnelle aux élections
européennes de 2019 par exemple jadot
tête de liste fait quasiment deux fois
le score de glace est inscrite
pour le non mais en tout cas ça ça dit
ça dit ça pourquoi ça décolle pas aussi
yannick jadot parce qu'on n'arrive pas
je pense quand on est français et qu on
fait autre chose dans la vie a vraiment
l'identifier et ce qu'il est ou pas un
peu du côté d'hidalgo c'est actuellement
les français est ce que par rapport à
lui revient on y reviendra à la gauche
dans leur
voiture le la thématique valérie
pécresse parce que ce qui était
intéressant dans le baromètre c'est que
vous vous tester des traits d'image
aussi gaël sliman je vais je vais en
reprendre quelques uns et puis après
vous allez pouvoir les analyser les
traits d'image en positif
dynamique compétente sympathique solide
ayant de l'autorité
rassembleuse eschede particulièrement
aux par rapport à d'autres personnalités
que vous testez sur ses traits d'image
premiers éléments et puis deuxième
élément peut-être est-ce que sont des
traits d'image qui sont classiques d'une
personnalité de droite alors oui elle
est particulièrement comme pour emmanuel
macron tout à l'heure nous sommes en
france comme nous sommes en france il
faut être humble quand on est un homme
politique ou une femme politique parce
que quand on est canton par exemple 55%
des français qui disent que vous n'êtes
pas rassembleuse et seulement 42% qui
disent que vous l'êtes oui c'est pas mal
du tout quand on a sympathique 51 % des
gens disent non non elle est pas du tout
sympathique mais et 47 qui disent oui
elle est bien c'est pas mal alors on a
tout un benchmark pour parler en
franglais de comparaison avec d'autres
personnalités politiques commençons pas
son principal rival emmanuel macron sur
tous ses attributs d'image elle fait
plutôt soit aussi bien soit mieux qu
emmanuel macron lorsqu'on le tester sur
ces mêmes crible d'image il ya de ça
quelques mois donc ça c'est pas mal ce
qui est plus compliqué pour elle est
alors auprès des sympathisants à l'air
c'est un carton elle elle oscille entre
75% et 90% sur la quinzaine du thème que
l'on teste avec des jugements
extrêmement extrêmement flatteur ce qui
est un petit peu plus compliqué pour
elle mais c'est aux logiques c'est
normal c'est quand on la compare à
emmanuel macron et qu'on demande aux
gens entre emmanuel macron et valérie
pécresse lequel est le plus capable de
gagner la présidentielle lequel est le
plus solide lequel est le plus capable
de diriger la france alors on voit on
voit dérouler les résultats de alors du
barreau matinée elle est à chaque fois
devancé par emmanuel macron vous voyez
que le total des deux par exemple
capable de diriger la france 36 +22 ça
n'a jamais fait sens donc ça signifie
que vous avez une part encore plus
importante de france est évidemment
qu'ils sont de gauche ou d'extrême
droite ou et qu'ils disent mais ni l'un
d'eux ne sont dans cette situation
ça c'est peut-être la principale
fragilité naturel normal qu'elle devra
contrer pendant sa campagne elle devra
peut-être rassuré sur le fait qu'elle
est proche des gens et sympathique mais
à la limite c'est pas centrale ce qui
sera central c'est d'expliquer en quoi
elle va être capable de l'emporter ça
c'est pour maintenir les voies qu'elle a
récupéré d'eric zemmour par exemple et
puis garder ses voix et l'air puisque
une partie de l'électorat et l'air
hésite entre emmanuel macron elle et
puis en quoi elle est capable de diriger
le pays et ça c'est le message qu'elle
va devoir porter c'est ce qu'elle va
devoir expliquer dans les semaines ou
dans les mois qui viennent ensuite petit
rebond sur notre échange précédent c'est
vrai que c'est quand même spectacle on a
beau dire après coup mais on l'avait
déjà vu et y compris moi vous le dire ce
soir on aurait peut-être pas parié les
uns et les autres qu'elle allait passer
de 9% d'intentions de vote à 19% sur
notre dernier sondage au doxa avec
mascara et l'ops on est étonné mais
après on regarde et on dit bah oui
c'était déjà arrivé à benoît hamon
c'était déjà arrivé à françois fillon
avant de retomber un petit peu donc
quand vous disiez quand on prend aux
points en trois jours on peut les
repères dans trois jours peut-être pas
en trois jours peut-être pas 11 points
mais il faut être prudent aussi quand on
est dans l'entourage de valérie pécresse
même si elle ne faisait pas une mauvaise
campagne si elle ne disait pas de
bêtises dans les semaines ou dans l'est
dans les mois qui viennent il est
possible qu'ils aient un petit effet de
redescendre ce serait assez fréquent
assez natural si on est dans le match
entre valérie pécresse et emmanuel
macron à nathalie morel est ce qu'ils
vont se battre un peu pour les mêmes
électeurs aussi ça fait partie des boucs
les enjeux des prochains mois oui oui
bien sûr parce que effectivement valérie
pécresse elle a gagné sur une ligne de
droite très affirmé la campagne pour le
congrès est là elle est contrainte de se
recentrer donc si elle se recentre elle
tombe sur qui sur la droite modérée qui
effectivement même si elle est partie sa
sage qu'elle pourrait il dire autant que
moi en tous les cas beaucoup considèrent
que lui a mené une politique de
centre-droit c'est en cela qu'on
considère que les électeurs sont partis
moi quand je regarde dans les gorges du
sahel et pardon aux intérêts elle est
symbolisée par edouard philippe oui
c'est ça l habituelle avait soutenu plus
ou moins
s'il m'en faire campagne alain juppé
lors de la primaire de la droite et donc
alain juppé c'est un des mentors de
d'edouard philippe oui mais en même
temps moi je note sur le sur votre
baromètre que quand même emmanuel macron
reste très soutenue par la gauche il ya
62 % de mémoire des électeurs de gauche
qui qui le trouve très bien qu'ils
trouvent considère que c'est un bon
président donc on voit bien que certes
il a une politique inhumaine politique
de centre-droit dirons nous mais les
sympathisants de centre gauche sont
toujours chez emmanuel macron pour la
simple et bonne raison c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas trouvé pour l'instant mieux
pour eux c'est donc à notre
ouïe valérie pécresse il va falloir
qu'elle fasse attention parce qu'elle
est sur une crête lui emmanuel macron
aussi il va falloir qu'il continue à
séduire l'électorat de centre droit sans
perdre son avec l'électorat qui l'a élu
il ya cinq ans un suivi est frappant
c'est en vous écoutant et d'ailleurs ça
a commencé dans vos titres thomas vous
avez dit la percée valérie pécresse
parce que moi ce qui m'intéresse
toujours c'est le récit médiatique que
l'on fait de sondage ou d'événements et
la géologie retenu quelques mots
première opposante à emmanuel macron
c'est ce que vous venez de dire
l'adversaire la plus dangereuse pour
emmanuel macron valérie pécresse
inquiète la majorité valérie pécresse
fait main basse sur la droite la percée
pécresse popularité grandissante tout ça
ce sont des mots répétés démultiplier je
ne dis pas que le français se fait dix
chaînes d'info et lille 15 journaux mais
quand même peut-être dans la voiture
peut-être en cuisinant etc il entend
c'est ses phrases là qui sont très
clairs et qu'ils donnent tout tout tout
c'est nul mais une unis d'un unanimité
une année
faut le couper en morceaux et très
médiatique et cet essai c'est vrai que
ça devient une vérité c'est à dire qu'on
a toujours dans ce récit médiatique qui
est une prophétie auto-réalisatrice
peut-être en tout cas à un instant t
bien sûr il ya vos sondages bien sûr il
ya des chiffres mais il y a les mots
aussi que les français entendent et vous
entendre peut-être jusqu'à noël et ça ça
va marquer peut-être l'intention de
voter parce que moi il me semble que
dans quand on compare emmanuel macron et
valérie pécresse le marqueur manif pour
tous de valérie pécresse est très fort
c'est à dire que c'est pour ça qu'elle
n'est pas edouard philippe valérie
pécresse être favorable à la manif pour
tous ça m'a marqué parce qu' edouard
philippe emmanuel macron tout ce champ
là de la droite centre et voir un tout
petit peu à droite mais en tout cas
centre et ce n'est pas du tout manif on
nous alors c'est intéressant mais il ya
un autre élément pour évaluer
effectivement cette percée de valérie
pécresse ce sont les attaques qu'elle
subit de la part des ministres ou des
élus de la majorité présidentielle un
exemple tient ce matin sur france info
gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement elle à la fébrilité comme
moteur et l'hypocrisie comme carburant
elle avait un programme qui a été
présenté dans le cadre de la primaire
avec notamment des mesures avec
lesquelles on n'est pas en accord
c'est-à-dire notamment des suppressions
massives de postes dans la fonction
publique indifférenciée puisqu'elle ne
dit pas où elle valait suppose 100000
donc ce qu'on peut attendre c'est une
nouvelle saignée dans l'hôpital c'est ça
qui on peut attendre de cette annonce là
il faut clarifier les choses et ensuite
elle a dit au lendemain de la primaire
j'avais mon projet mais eric ciotti a
fait 40 % à la primaire est donc je vais
devoir assaisonner mon projet en
reprenant des mesures d'eric ciotti ce
qui est assez curieux parce que des
mesures en général vous demander si
elles sont bonnes ou pas pour le pays
vous les reprenez pas parce que
quelqu'un a fait 40 % c'est typiquement
de la tambouille que nous ont rejoints
par mathieu souk rc voila ca qu un vrai
signe de la menace alors je sais pas si
c'est un signe de la manière de la
menace pécresse en tout cas ce cas c'est
la perception par le par le gouvernement
et par là c'est un renvoi à l'envoyeur
valérie pécresse depuis la primaire est
depuis sa victoire évidemment a fait des
modèles macron sa cible essentielle je
pense quand même que valérie pécresse
peut se heurter d'abord un problème de
sincérité ou d'insincérité quart
j'entends ce que disait laetitia à
l'instant il n'empêche que marine le pen
n'a pas eu totalement tort en disant
juste après sa victoire qu'elle était
prolonge la plus macro compatible des
candidats à la primaire ait l'air il
fait assez peu de doute que en matière
économique et sociale elle n'est pas
très éloigné dans les douars philippe
oudin bruno le maire
elle peut avoir sur la famille alors
c'est vraiment des positions très
claires en matière économique et sociale
mais je pense qu'elle peut avoir par
ailleurs un problème de cohérence ou
d'incohérences parce qu'elle a ce grand
écart à faire entre précisément la
droite modérée qui aujourd'hui se
retrouvent chez emmanuel macron et la
droite radicalisée incarné par eric
ciotti qui penche plutôt du côté zemmour
est donc évidemment elle pourrait tout à
fait se faire écarter les eaux gère en
général ces tensions où on compense ces
tensions par un leadership fort ce que
nicolas sarkozy a fait de manière
remarquable en 2007 aura-t-elle un
leadership suffisamment fort pour
arriver à tenir les deux bouts voilà la
campagne en fait le dira la percée qui
est la sienne aujourd'hui ne garantit
rien pour la suite si ce n'est peut-être
une chose elle la prémunir du risque
aujourd'hui d'hidalgo isation en quelque
sorte cercle elle est montée
suffisamment haut pour a priori ne pas
redescendre aussi bas qu anne hidalgo se
situe aujourd'hui si on fait parler
absolument mais jamais elle n'est jamais
montée très haut mais elle a réussi à
descendre très bas là où valérie
pécresse est aujourd'hui probablement un
peu protégés alors l'un des axes d'attac
de valérie pécresse parce qu'évidemment
on se rend des coûts se rend coup pour
coup concerne la communication du
président là public et notamment son
émission sur tf1 demain soir valérie
pécresse qui a vu sa propre émission qui
était prévu sur bfmtv annulé parce que
le président est en face sur tf1 et les
dirigeant de bfm tv ont dit très
clairement nous notre job c'est de
commenter les propos présidentiels donc
on reporte la venue de valérie pécresse
elle en appelle à candidater l'air au
csa et le président du csa avait rappelé
la règle c'est ya quelques jours ici au
sénat lors d'une audition sur la
concentration des médias en écoute
depuis 89 donc on applique les
rédactions applique une réelle qui
consiste à faire la distinction
entre d'un côté la fonction du chef de
l'état gèle et régalienne dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions qui n'est
pas comptabilisé et le chef de l'état
cpt décembre dans le débat politique
national qui lui est comptabilisée et il
compte miser à la fois hors période
électorale
les compteurs fonctionnent toute l'année
et à partir
du mois de janvier qu'ils soient
déclarés ou pas pouvant peut-être
considéré comme candidat très humaine
son temps de parole qui sera
comptabilisé au même titre que les
candidats d'ores et déjà dense et déjà
des chariots ont ce débat on l'a peu
près à chaque élection présidentielle
mais il n'empêche que il mérite d'être
posée est ce que vous y voyez une forme
de distorsion dans l' équilibre
démocratique et peut-être est-ce que ces
règles et vous semble un peu obsolète
aujourd'hui des risques alors oui je
pense que ce serait fins et ce serait
très compliqué de ne pas dire c'est une
distorsion démocratique on l'a vous avez
raison tout les élections tous les
présidents l'ont fait emmanuel macron
n'est pas pire que ses prédécesseurs de
ce point de vue là mais c'est c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas légitime en démocratie vous ne
pouvez pas faire ce qu'il va faire sur
tf1 ce qu'il avait déjà fait
alors qu'il était sous un prétexte qu
évident il était censé parler du coc vie
de la dernière fois c'est à dire faire
l'article est présenté son bilan sous le
meilleur jour possible et que ça ne soit
pas décompté moi ce que j'entends là
indiqué par le président du csa suggère
c'est comme ça que je le comprends je
vais peut-être
je comprend peut-être de travers mais ce
que je comprends c'est que ce qui ce qui
aura lieu demain soir devrait
normalement être décomptés pour moi
c'est comme ça je le comprends et je
pense que si c'est pas cette fois-ci ou
à l'avenir notre démocratie mûrit elle
grandit on ne pourra plus avoir j'en
suis à peu près convaincu ça ne sera
plus accepté ces phénomènes de président
qui se déclarent au mois de mars c'est
ce que faisait tous ses prédécesseurs en
février mars le plus tard possible pour
pouvoir faire campagne tranquillement
pendant des mois et des mois tout en
étant président je pense que ça ça ne
sera plus possible alors peut-être pas
pour cette élection mais peut-être pour
la prochaine en plus c'est un casse-tête
faire qu'on imagine un président en
déplacement sur un thème régalien donc
alors éclaté mais quand il leur
est très simple la promesse on n'a pas
encore entendu mais la porte est
régalien ou pas à demain il est il est
censé faire le bilan de son de son
quinquennat est vanté ces mesures et
affronter toutes ces difficultés tout ça
à part d'ombré dirait françois
mitterrand donc pour moi c'est
typiquement quelque chose qui relève de
la campagne de l'auto promotion ça
devrait être décompté ses prédécesseurs
l'ont fait avant lui faudra qu'un jour
ça soit décompté nathalie morel votre
avis là-dessus ce qui est important ce
qui effectivement vous avez totalement
raison il est en campagne tout le monde
le sait tout le monde le sait que je
veux dire avec même s'il ne se présente
pas lui même ce sera pour son successeur
qu'est ce qui ce qui est important de
savoir c'est pourquoi il le fait
maintenant parce que quand il a quand il
a parlé le dise le 10 novembre sous les
prétextes kovy doux et nous a annoncé
les autres p r etc on nous avait dit à
l'elysée de toute façon il n'y aura pas
d'autres prises de parole à part la
conférence de presse sur la psf yeux qui
était effectivement dans les tuyaux
il y aura pas d'autre il y aura pas
d'autres prises de parole avant le 31
décembre las il ya une émission de deux
heures ou deux heures et demie à une
heure de grande écoute sur la plus
grande chaîne de france c'est qu'il ya
une raison la raison elle s'appelle
effectivement valérie pécresse non pas
tant parce que riz pécresse les inquiète
quoique mais c'est une façon en macro ni
on théorise le fait que pendant les
vacances scolaires et les vacances
scolaires je vous rappelle que c'est ben
48 heures
les familles vont se retrouver et vont
se retrouver il va bien falloir avoir
des sujets de conversation de la dame de
noël parce que j'ai des sentiments
malheureusement pour avoir pas mal
d'expérience qu'on n'en parlait pas lors
des précédents scrutins celi je vous
prie
ses soucis
une des sessions sarkozy aimait ça
du coup l'objectif c'est de ne pas
laisser tout le champ de la dinde de
noël j'allais dire
autour de valérie pécresse qui
effectivement fait une percée importante
et l'autre étant eric zemmour s'est en
fait les deux pôles d'attraction de la
gamme comprend que c'est une façon de la
commande et pas spectateur un peu fendre
l'armure parler de lui parler de choses
que justement c'est un président qui
finalement on ne connaît pas tant que ça
même si on voit tous les jours à la
télévision ce sera un sujet de
conversation et c'est le but de cette
émission je crois mathieu souquet à
fendre l'armure c'est drôle parce que
non mais c'est très bien il faut il faut
avoir ces référents cela en tête vous
avez vraiment le sentiment que les
français connaissent pas emmanuel macron
non je pense que pardon oui il fait
devenir une cible privilégiée il a
plutôt intérêt à conserver son armure au
contraire et à se protéger des flèches
qu'il va prendre je suis un peu un peu
plus nuancée par rapport au débat qu'on
a alors d'abord sur la distorsion des
prises de parole qui précisément
emmanuel macron est un président qui je
mêle à la période qu'ovide à part est un
président qui s'exprime en réalité assez
peu emmanuel macron il fait pas de
conférence de presse il donne pas
d'interview c'est relativement à alors
même qu'au cours des dernières semaines
et des derniers mois on a pardon pour
l'expression mais manger d'abord du
débat écolo puis ensuite mangé de la
primaire ait l'air j'ai l'impression
qu'on a bien plus jurer entendu une
valérie pécresse qu'un emmanuel macron
au cours des dernières semaines donc je
ne sais pas s'il ya une une telle
distorsion que cela dans les expressions
qui pourraient derrière introduire une
forme de billets j'ai un petit doute là
tu m'en suis de toute façon fait son
fiancé au csa pour contrôler les
l'équilibré des temps de parole oui et
je comprends ce que ce que dit gaëlle et
en même temps quand est-ce qu'on
commence si c'est pas la date du 1er
janvier et s'il faut quand est-ce qu'on
commence en janvier jean luc mélenchon
aujourd'hui oui mais mais mais jean-luc
mélenchon est candidat depuis plus d'un
an marine le pen pareil donc à partir de
quel moment on considère que le
président en exercice potentiel
successeur de lui même et est il lui
même en campagne et j'ai pas le
sentiment d'ailleurs que son agenda si
on regarde réellement la campagne
approche c'est vrai les commentateurs
s'excite un peu c'est vrai mais je ne
suis pas je suis pas sûr que l'agenda du
président s'organise selon lui très
différemment de la façon dont ils
s'organisaient il ya un an où il ya deux
ans voilà j'ai un petit doute là dessus
mais c'est sur le passage là c'est pas
tellement sûr c'est sur ce passage
télévisé lag qui a priori on l'a pas vu
encore évidemment mais tel qu'il est
présenté on a vraiment le sentiment à
lire ce qui en est dit ou entendu qu'il
y en ai dit que c'est s'est présentée ou
perçu comme une façon de vanter son
bilan de justifier son bilan et parce
que d'affronter ses démons en parlant
vraisemblablement de sujets difficiles
comme la sphère benalla donc si ça ce
n'est pas si ça ce n'est pas rentrer en
campagne alors en tout état de cause il
est impossible pour amener le mot qu'on
me semble-t-il d'être officiellement
candidat à ce stade car j'entends le
confort qu'il peut y avoir à se déclarer
le plus tard possible mais je vois
l'inconfort qu'il y aurait à se déclarer
au sein lozériens les français
légitimement et tous ses opposants lui
tomberait immédiatement dessus en disant
mais il n'est plus président il est
candidat or nous avons besoin d'un
président bien sûr donc au là dessus je
pense qu'on peut considérer que dans un
mandat qui est quand même relativement
court un mandat de cinq ans il faut
rester que jusqu'au dernier quart
d'heure on a essayé des pains mauvaise
vie où doit réformer jusqu'au jusqu'au
delà c'est vrai que c'est un outrage
vraiment une arme massive de
communication parce que il n'aime pas
trop ça et vous avez raison la
confrontation avec les journalistes
oncle à choisir tf1 choisir ses
journalistes cela je dis pas que c'est
lui qui a choisi mais en général ça se
passe quand même aussi un petit brison
propose une analyse
objective il pense qu'il va les
atteindre 1 en employant à ce moyen là
donc on verra bien
on se parle de la gauche c'est primaire
impossible
zoom sur la gauche avec tout de suite
steve jourdain bonsoir steve bon nous
rejoindre on va voir ce que à l'agglo
jean notre baromètre met d'abord cette
question existentielle pour la gauche
très bonne question excellente question
à laquelle même les dirigeants de gauche
je serais vraiment répondre je pense
thomas ici au sénat chez les socialistes
on nous dit aujourd'hui oui ça discute
oui ça négocie oui l'initiative d'anne
hidalgo a fait un peu bouger les choses
mais impossible de savoir aujourd'hui où
cette initiative a vraiment nous mener
on rembobine peut être un peu tôt marc
au tour sur cette semaine folle qui a
commencé mercredi dernier anne hidalgo
s'invite alors au jt de tf1 la candidate
socialiste fait volte face et propose
d'organiser une grande primaire de la
gauche une offre qui est là à nouveau
mises sur la table dimanche c'était lors
d'un meeting organisé à perpignan
écoutez j'ai proposé publiquement
sincèrement le seul chemin qui
permettent de se rassembler aujourd'hui
celui de la primaire avant le premier
tour là où les appareils politiques
n'ont pas réussi
seuls les citoyens peuvent aujourd'hui
nous rassembler
et pour l'instant les autres candidats
sont pas vraiment respectée
réceptif à rester titre les perspectives
pas un mot france c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire ils sont pas ni réceptif wii
accueille lyon ne sont rien du tout pour
l'instant on va voir cette image que
vous avez forcément vu circuler ce
week-end arnaud montebourg qui est lui
plutôt
favorable à ce qu'on rebattent les
cartes à gauche arnaud montebourg qui
tente vainement de joindre par téléphone
yannick jadot anne hidalgo fabien au sel
et jean luc mélenchon arnaud montebourg
qui se prend une veste disons le mais
qui ne se décourage pas pour autant il
dira plus tard avoir pu échanger et
longuement avec anne hidalgo et jean luc
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon qui a
accueilli d'une primaire plutôt
froidement on va dire
c'est d'une hypocrisie totale ces gens
là ne cherche pas l'union une sortie de
secours ces gens là c'est là vous voyez
que le parti socialiste n'est plus un
parti de gouvernement sont capables
d'imaginer qu'à quatre mois d'une
élection sans programme on va organiser
une primaire et puis ensuite on
discutera du programme nous ça fait dix
ans qu'on met au point ces gens là ces
gens là on tendait anne hidalgo et
arnaud montebourg ces gens là ont aussi
essuyé un refus de la part des
communistes de fabien roussel il
attendait une réponse de yannick jadot
sur qui repose aujourd'hui un peu toute
la pression le candidat écologiste qui
détient d'une certaine manière l'une des
clés de l'union il ne décolle pas dans
les sondages il devra peut-être prendre
certaines décisions difficiles dans les
semaines qui viennent il était sur
france info hier matin écoutez le
c'est intéressant tous ces responsables
politiques qui font de la politique
aujourd'hui par twitter en se filmant et
1 sans en parler directement
désolé moi ça me fascine pour sauver une
candidature en difficulté pour sauver le
parti socialiste on nous explique qu'il
faut faire une énième primaire on parle
pas du fond et on prend en otage le
moment où il était temps de parler aux
françaises et aux français en bilan de
cette semaine folle l'union c'est pas
pour tout de suite l'union est un combat
à 10 et georges marchais un combat
auquel auraient peut-être pourrait
peut-être participer christiane taubira
dont on dit qu'elle devrait prendre la
parole dans les heurts dans les jours
qui viennent christiane taubira qui dans
notre sondage doxa de votre sondage
aussi izia elle fait la course en tête
chez les sympathisants de gauche 54%
d'adhésion auprès des sympathisants de
gauche elle fait mieux que jean luc
mélenchon elle fait mieux aussi que
yannick jadot reste à savoir si elle
aura vraiment envie de rentrer dans ce
qui ressemble aujourd'hui à un bon
binôme merci steve pour ceux se rappelle
alors on a en effet ce premier zoom on
peut zoomer encore un peu plus laetitia
sur la journée de mercredi oui la
journée folle de mercredi on a quand
même fait demi-tour en chemin anne
hidalgo qui étaient partis pour une
étape de son tour de france dans sa
campagne devait aller lucky man dans les
charentes maritimes et puis elle
s'arrête à poitiers elle n'a pas été
jusqu'au bout et elle a décidé de
reprendre le tgv dans le sens inverse
direction paris pourquoi apparemment dit
elle parce qu'on vient de déclencher le
plan blanc dans les hôpitaux donc la
maire de paris se doit d'être dans la
capitale pour des réunions d'urgence
même message au fait ce même et après
mais l'a reconnu elle a confessé
s'expliquer dans la presse ces mêmes est
penché ce qui m'a un peu surprise est là
elle a parlé d'un électrochoc qu'elle
voulait mettre à la gauche et que
c'était cette proposition elle est
réussie c'est depuis plusieurs semaines
donc elle a dit qu'elle avait senti ce
moment dans ce tgv qui l'emmenait à la
rochelle je ne sais pas pourquoi et qu'
elle avait comme ça d'instinct voulu
remonter à paris elle avait téléphoné à
tf1 décroché trois minutes pour aller
sur le plateau est proposé cette
primaire alors on l'a entendu dans la
chronique de steve tous ses adversaires
disent que c'est une sortie de secours
et même à l'intérieur du parti
socialiste 1 ses détracteurs disent qu
effectivement ça lui permettra peut-être
après noël de partir par une petite
porte celle de derrière vous savez tout
au fond thomas et de laisser la place
peut-être à cette star qui est attendu
mais peut-être un peu trop fantasmer il
me semble christiane taubira je parle
même pas de bernard cazeneuve qu'on a
vite enterré mais qui pourraient aussi
pourquoi pas je ne sais pas si vous
l'avez testé la gueule chine il est plus
loin
dans le peuple de gauche c'est vrai que
ces figures la fédérer davantage et
c'est intéressant merci laetitia gaël
sliman parce que effectivement dans ce
palmarès de l'adhésion dont vous faites
sympathisants gauche sympathisants de
droite dans le palmarès de l'adhésion
sympathisants de gauche on à christiane
taubira qui arrive en tête avec 54%
devant jean-luc mélenchon et yannick
jadot mais alors ce qui m'a surpris
c'est qu'ils arrivent en quatre et ans 5
roselyne bachelot et edouard philippe
chez les sympathisants de gauche qui ont
deux hidalgo et arnaud que j'aime
j'allais vous lire ce qu'il ya de siad
amusant c'est le combo c'est à dire
steve dans son brillant exposé sur notre
sondage vous faisait la comparaison avec
ses suivants et vous venez de le faire
aussi thomas mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que vous venez de parler d' anne
hidalgo on n'en parle même plus elle est
dans le palmarès mais elle est tellement
loin qu'on a bola chercher on ne voit
pas elle est à 34 % de code d'adhésion
auprès des sympathisants de gauche et
vous l'avez dit thomas on est à 50 4%
pour christiane taubira numéro un est de
très loin dans le coeur des
sympathisants de gauche donc il ya un
sujet hidalgo évidemment sa campagne ne
décolle pas dans nos intentions de vote
les la dernière intentions de vote qu'on
a publié avec mascarel le partenaire qui
nous accompagne aussi sur le baromètre
politique elle est à 3% a une marge
d'erreur statistique à elle pour faire 4
mais c'est quand même c'est quand même
extrêmement médiocre l on aille à nick
shadow qui à 6% alors que le contexte
dans lequel s'inscrit cette déclaration
d'anne hidalgo il faut bien comprendre
c'est un contexte de de panique à bord à
la fois pour elle et pour tout le peuple
de gauche et tous les candidats de
gauche ils sont faits à combien
mélenchon étaient 10% mais on peut
penser qu'il aura du mal à dépasser
cette espèce de plafond de verre parce
qu'il sait il a beaucoup abîmé son image
avec le fameux la république c'est moi
est-ce que je ne sais pas si vous avez
des infos sur l'hypothèse christiane
taubira mais est-ce qu'elle songe
vraiment à ceux à se présenter un athée
limoges oui oui manifestement elle y
songe elle y réfléchit alors entre y
penser et réfléchir il ya quand même un
gamin parce que je vous rappelle que au
parti socialiste il se rappelle quand
même quand 2002 elle a fait 2 % et que
c'est quand même les 2% qui ont manqué à
à lionel jospin ça veut dire très
clairement il ya beaucoup d' il ya des
gens au parti socialiste qui ne seraient
pas prêts à la soutenir il faut bien
comprendre si vous voulez qu'aujourd'hui
ce qui se joue là à gauche c'est patent
l'élection présidentielle aujourd'hui au
parti socialiste ils ont compris qu'ils
avaient perdue aujourd'hui c'est la
survie du parti qui est en train de se
jouer donc c'est comment on fait une
alliance ou pas avec yannick jadot 2
façon à ce qu'on ressorte aux élections
législatives avec un accord de
législatives suffisamment fort pour
qu'on ait un gros groupe
de députés qui nous permettent d'avoir
des financements et pour qu'enfin on
refonde le parti socialiste avec les
commères des grandes villes etc c'est ça
qui est en train de se jouer donc
j'allais dire peu importe qui tiendra le
flambeau socialiste ce qui se joue
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui là alors qu'on
n'est même pas en 2022 c'est l'accord
pour laisser si les futures législatives
face à nadal go c'est l'erreur de libye
est fort ou pas
beaucoup le disent à mon avis non parce
que le problème si vous voulez c'est
vrai qu'il l'a imposé c'est vrai qu'elle
a été imposée comme ça son primaire mais
il avait qui d'autre bernard cazeneuve
vous l'avais dit à essayer ça n'a pas
marché c'est olivier faure qui l'a
écarté apparemment d'après ce que dit
est ce que vous avez senti dans la rue
qui défend des idées à faire le saut lui
manque que bernard cazeneuve soir notre
prochain candidat il n'y a pas eu d
lankaise n'offrent sincèrement laëtitia
était un élan taubira pour boucler sur
ce thème là bas je
l aime se faire désirer peut-être
c'est peut-être un peu le jeu de ces de
ces derniers jours mais des voix
s'élèvent pour qu'elles soient elles
fassent irruption encore une fois le
désir peut prendre corps par par défaut
de concurrence réelle je me permets un
parallèle sur la situation qui est la
nôtre avec quand même la situation de
2010 est en réalité si on additionne
tous les scores la gauche n'est pas
véritablement plus faible qu'elle ne
l'était en dominé 17 en 2010 est elle
fait 25% il ya moins de candidature
puisque jadot rallye amont et parce que
le parti communiste soutient jean luc
mélenchon mais en réalité le nombre de
candidatures qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
le nombre de candidatures qu'on a à peu
près à toutes les élections
présidentielles 2010 est mis à part en
tout état de cause l'addition des scores
c'est à peu près ce que faisait la
gauche à la présidentielle de 2017 ta
différence c'est que là elle est très
dispersé personne ne prend le leadership
si ce n'est jean luc mélenchon qui en a
qui en est à sa troisième candidature et
qui paraît peut-être un peu usés dont on
n'imagine pas dont on imagine
difficilement qu'il pourrait bénéficier
d'un élan comparable à celui d'il ya
cinq ans juste une chose encore une fois
dans les enquêtes que nous faisons à la
fondation jean jaurès nous observons que
la demande d'unité et très forte qu'elle
est très forte dans toutes les
composantes de la gauche y compris la
france insoumise deuxième dimension
élections primaires à gauche absolument
les préoccupations sont les mêmes de la
france insoumise jusqu aux écolos et au
ps c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas de
gauches irréconciliables ont tout état
de cause les militants de gauche ne se
considère pas irréconciliable entre eux
et il y a donc une attente assez forte
un tout dernier mot il nous reste
86% sur le sondage qu'on a qu'on a
publié
parmi les sympathisants de gauche et
vous avez raison quel que soit le bord
politique
j'aimerais qu'on parle de santé parce
que c'est un autre sondage baromètre
doxa l'hôpital et la santé enjeu majeur
vote des français en perspective de
cette élection prêt est ce que c'est un
peu conjoncturel parce que de nouveaux
on parle beaucoup les deux co vide
cinquième sixième vague les de manger
halal c'est à la fois lié à une
conjoncture actuelle et c'est plus
fondamentale que ça c'est un gros
baromètre qu'on fait avec one payne sur
la santé auprès de 3000 français auprès
de patients auprès de personnes qui ont
fréquenté les hôpitaux et on a la chance
d'avoir déjà posé ces questions il y a
cinq ans lors de la précédente élection
on à 68% des français qui nous disent
aujourd'hui qu'ils feront de ces
questions autour de la santé et
l'hôpital un enjeu majeur de leur vote à
la présidentielle c'est plus 13 points
par rapport à la même question que nous
avons posée il ya cinq ans j'ajoute
quand même et puisqu'on parle de l'état
de la gauche que pouvoir d'achat et
santé sont structurellement les deux
priorités majeures des français et que
ce sont des sujets sur lesquels a priori
ge dans toutes les enquêtes depuis
trente ans on considérait que la gauche
était mieux armé plus capable que la
droite ou le centre-droit d'algoé partie
sur le pouvoir d'achat dans son tour de
france était la thématique majeure oui
mais avec peu de contenu peu de capacité
à bhl il ya un vrai sujet pouvoir aller
sur ce terrain là quand on est de gauche
et pouvoir effectivement s'unir en
essayant de ne pas mélanger la carpe et
le lapin est peut-être concentrer sur
écologistes et socialistes plutôt que
d'aller chercher un mélenchon se serait
peut-être une solution pour eux merci
beaucoup merci à tous le prochain
baromètre ce sera 20 janvier ce sera
autour du 20 janvier autour du 20
janvier
c'est dingue ou pourra poser la question
à la base
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ces débats mathieu le
soutien rappelle le titre de votre livre
2022 la percée populiste qui est donc
flory a publié génie percée flamber ce
qui s'est passé l'an
et puis franchement essais chez plon
merci ça c'est bon à l'essence pub